like most people in this country I want
to see more action on climate change in
fact Labor's got a bold and ambitious
plan that would deliver hugely towards
achieving Net Zero but also helping
bring down people's bills deliver our
energy security by racing towards
um a net zero bubbling a green energy
superpower and I think I think those are
the sorts of solutions our country needs
I think what some of those tactics and
some of those protesters do is actually
really self-defeating because I think
most people in this country are worried
about their bills they can see the
argument as to how building more
renewable energy new nuclear uh you know
expanding Britain's energy domestic
energy Supply and production would
deliver more jobs and bring down bills
and help achieve Net Zero I think the
case the argument's one certainly as far
as labor is concerned and when people go
about disrupting other people's lives
rather than building a bigger tent with
more supporters they end up alienating
people and that's my problem with their
tactics presumably you support peaceful
protests though so what's your message
to them this weekend I I think there are
ways of grabbing attention without
causing disruption to people's lives and
when they do that they actually alienate
people and push people away from a cause
which I think is crucial to our
country's future to our planet's future
so I you know any campaigner worth their
thought will be thinking how do we build
the tent of support how do we grow the
coalition to force decision makers into
action that's how pressure groups can be
most effective what what they're doing
it may sometimes grab the headlines but
often for all the wrong reasons and
alienate people from the cause and
that's not surely not what they want and
briefly if you can because you've got
lots of other things to talk about are
you worried about the London Marathon
being disrupted I really hope it's not
people train for the London Marathon
whether they are Elite athletes or
people who were doing it to set a
personal Target or to raise money for
brilliant causes right across the
country so don't disrupt the marathon it
goes right back to the heart of what I
was just saying you know Marathon
disruption it might dominate the
headlines it will turn people off in
terms of the cause and let down all of
those Runners and their supporters
cheering them on who want a great day
out and an opportunity to raise loads of
money for good causes and I should say
Extinction Rebellion says that they
won't we'll see what other groups decide
over the weekend but let's move to what
we have as our top story today and this
is the prime minister deliberating about
a Dominic rap his deputies future having
received the report that's been drawn up
over the allegations of bullying against
him what do you make of the fact that
we've had no decision even though as we
understand it the prime minister's had
this report since yesterday morning well
it tells us there's certainly a case to
answer I've got to say rishi's doing
that it's got no one to blame but
himself these allegations were hanging
in the air when Dominic Robb was
appointed Deputy Prime Minister indeed I
would argue Dominic Robb shouldn't have
been given the the job on the basis he
was on a sun lounger during the
evacuation of Kabul when diplomats and
members of armed forces working really
hard to have to to evacuate people from
Afghanistan so I don't think Dominic
Robb should be in the job and I think
you know the day that Rishi sunak has
spent deliberating on the future of one
person is a day he should have spent
deliberating on how to tackle the
biggest crisis in the history of the NHS
or how to deliver Justice on Art streets
or or how to tackle the cost of living
crisis which is which is soaring in
terms of food prices and the pain in
people's pockets well there are clearly
a lot of issues that he is dealing with
however it's not unreasonable is it for
him to take his time over what is no
doubt a detailed report after all Adam
Tolley has spent five months drawing it
together and it also involves the career
of of somebody he works with it's fair
enough that he should take its time
isn't it I think certainly the process
has got to be fair to the individual and
to the people who put in complaints
certainly my anxiety is that what Rishi
sunak is deliberate rating on isn't the
substance of the report but the politics
of this whether or not he's going to
stand by what he said outside Downing
Street about restoring trust and
standards in public life or whether or
not he's going to be strong enough to
stand up to people in his own party he
would he would inevitably upset if he
sacks Dominic Robin I do think Rishi
sunat's got formed for weakness he
appointed Sue Ella braveman as Home
Secretary even though she had been fired
for a national security breach this is
not a strong leader able to stand up to
the right of his party would you like to
see the prime minister's ethics adviser
Laurie Magnus take a look at this report
that that may be helpful to the prime
minister in informing his judgment But
ultimately the prime minister's got to
make a decision he can't keep on
dithering and delaying or passing the
buck to someone else ultimately it's
it's on him it's his judgment as to who
he points to high office and who he
dismisses and I'm afraid he's got a
really poor track record of putting
people who are not good enough in some
of the highest offices in the land well
Dominic Rob has maintained as far as
this issue is concerned that he's
behaved professionally throughout as we
understand that he continues to maintain
that do you think you've seen any
evidence to dispute that uh well
obviously I I don't have the pleasure if
that's the right word of working with
Dominic rub in the in the ministry of
justice but those allegations as I say
were hanging around when he was first
appointed I do think we need to take
issues of of bullying in the workplace
seriously and I've never worked in an
environment where if people are bullied
you they get you get the best out of
them any good leader any good manager
will tell you that the best workplaces
the most productive workplaces are those
where people feel supported and
motivated inspired to do their very best
work and that never happens in a in an
environment where they're subject to
bullying or intimidation